[Musique]
populaire bobos et bariolés le quartier
de kreuzberg est un nid d'oiseau rare
allen et be love each y est resté perché
depuis qu'il a quitté la bosnie en 1993
dans ce quartier une personne sur deux
est artiste on est en rapport avec l'art
de la chine base windows tu sors de chez
toi tu on sait jamais sur qui tu vas
tomber plus de femmes en burqa défoncé
rentrant d'une teuf arickx des besoins
ou alors juste des gens normaux qui vont
au boulot
allen 38 ans est photographe
il avait 18 ans quand la guerre a éclaté
en bosnie comme 350000 bosniaque il
s'est réfugié en allemagne il a appris
la photo à berlin mais sa matière
première c'est la bosnie ça c'est un
combat de vache en bosnie là bas c'est
pas comme en espagne ces animaux contre
animaux ou alors les mecs contre eux
mais qu'ils m'aiment sortent même
[Rires]
mais allen n'est pas toujours aussi
débonnaire et ses instantanés aussi
esthétique photographier la bosnie s'est
couché ses pires souvenirs sur papier
glacé un manant que la team clic mon
oncle a perdu ses deux fils pendant la
guerre ça c'est à sens qui most dans ma
ville natale
c'est une morgue improvisée dans
laquelle on entreposait les cadavres
sortis des charniers mon oncle n'y est
jamais allé j'y allais à sa place
j'allais chercher dans les listes les
noms des corps qui avaient pu être
identifiés
là où on pensait que mes cousins avaient
été tués
tu les a retrouvés non j'en ai retrouvé
qu'un seul l'autre est toujours porté
disparu
pendant la guerre allen a été enfermé
par les serbes durant quatre mois quatre
mois de terreur dans un de ces camps
dont la découverte bouleversée alors
l'opinion internationale
quand quelqu'un vient truc pareil je
crois qu'il le train jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie la bosnie c'est le conflit le
plus meurtrier d'europe depuis 1945
en 1992 la fédération yougoslave se
disloque
les bosniaques vote leur indépendance
mais les serbes revendique le pays
s'en suivent quatre années de guerre et
d'épuration ethnique effroyable bilan
deux cent mille morts -dont 160 mille
bosniaque les accords de dayton met fin
au conflit en 1995 deux nouvelles
frontières sont dessinés la bosnie est
scindé en deux régions envers la
fédération de bosnie herzégovine où
cohabitent bosniaque et croate
en rouge la république serbe de bosnie
l'allemagne nourrit des rapports ambigus
avec ces réfugiés bosniaques
après les avoir accueillis en masse site
où la guerre terminée
l'état a tout fait pour les renvoyer
chez eux neuf bosniaque sur dix ont été
expulsés d'exa daala toi vite chez de
ceux qui sont restés sont mariés a été
tué par un sniper serbe arrivé ici elle
trouve refuge à sud ouest europe à une
association d aide aux femmes des
balkans désormais elle y travaille c'est
madame chedli ch
la fondatrice qui l'a embauché madame
chaliche nous a orientés vers les
thérapeutes pour nous aider à surmonter
notre traumatisme c'était un travail de
longue haleine
un vrai combat pour convaincre les
politiques allemands que ce type de
traumatisme était une maladie
attestation médicale avocat sud est
europe à employer tous les recours pour
permettre à ces femmes de rester à
berlin
alors maintenant qu'on est là on cuisine
on brode sur ses mouchoirs le nom de
leur mari enfants ou amis disparus
sa mode pas prochainement être échangé
malo pour s'amuser chez les vendeurs
cousus ensemble ces mouchoirs formeront
un patchwork de 30 mètres de long
ici on partage le poids du deuil
l'objectif c'est de les aider à se
débarrasser de leurs identités de
victimes pour que par la suite elle
puisse se consacrer pleinement à leur
nouvelle vie ici
les femmes ont un lieu où se retrouver
les hommes ont le leur
allen a au moins remporté une chose avec
lui à berlin c'est sa foi
les bosniaques sont musulmans ici ils
ont leurs propres centres culturels
islamiques y règne une atmosphère de
place du village et de pieuses
camaraderie comme un zoo comme ici tu
peux venir manger le midi s il y à une
bibliothèque pour bouquiner
c'est un endroit tu peux discuter de
tous les problèmes sexuels familiaux et
même de voisinage à l'heure du prêche du
vendredi la salle de prière affiche
complet dans l'ex yougoslavie le
bosniaque musulman a toujours côtoyé le
croate catholique et le serbe orthodoxe
mais pendant la guerre la pratique de
l'islam était un motif de persécution
côté serbe
l'allemagne est un pays où l'on peut
vivre pleinement et librement notre
religion
on en est bien conscient les nouilles et
musulmans de bosnie on en est d'autant
plus conscient on a acquis cette liberté
au prix d'une guerre l'allemagne
n'accueille pas que des bosniaques
musulmans allen arrancars avec son pote
robert un catholique de bosnie dans ce
snack tenu par un albanais on déguste
les spécialités des balkans sans se
soucier de leur pays d'origine les
baklavas vous savez depuis la nuit des
temps
lorient jusqu'aux balkans en passant par
berlin a toujours la même tête
le clash culturel baklava et qu'aucun
change
seuls les baklavas reste
j'ai lu un bouquin d'un historien
allemand qui se demandaient pourquoi
l'allemagne était intervenue si tard en
bosnie du coup c'est nous qui avons
morfler et pourquoi il aurait dû
intervenir
pourquoi toujours remettre la faute sur
les autres non mais tu vois bien c'était
la même chose au kosovo il ya des
intérêts derrière mais qu'est ce que
l'allemagne à avoir exposé à faire tout
ce que nos politiciens ont fait les
allemands n'ont rien à voir là dedans
pourquoi accuser l'allemagne c'est quoi
l'allemagne
c'est une société plutôt cool qu'est-ce
qu'on veut plus les bosniaques ne nous
auraient jamais accueilli comme les
allemands nous ont accueillis allen et
robert ont la vie devant eux
ici à berlin leurs aïeux en revanche ont
laissé la plus grande partie de la leur
en bosnie là bas il avait pour habitude
de travailler la terre alors d'exadata
et son association ont créé ce jardin
communautaire au fond de ce potager
divers mûrissent a installé ses ruches
comme au pays
[Musique]
ces rats des imams star les blacks
l'avis de muricy si vaudra toujours plus
que celle qu'il aurait eu là bas
sa maison est aujourd'hui habitée par
des serbes en région serbes de bosnie
est décalé d'un an
on ne goûte que ce soit sur leur terre
ou dans une allemagne parfois
inhospitalière les bosniaques de berlin
n'ont jamais baissé la tête
[Musique]